discussion over when and where to use a
mask does continue tonight new
frustrations about
kids wearing masks in schools yeah
parents are sounding off to the school
district and as victoria saha explains
they too want restrictions eased on mask
mandates
when can staff and students remove masks
at schools
it's a question parents want answered
this is psychological warfare on our
children
do the right thing unmask our children
and
pay attention to what all of us are
saying thursday's school district
meeting got heated
some parents showed up saying they don't
want their children to wear masks in
classrooms they need to show us that
they believe in the science or they
don't
if they believe in the science and they
believe in the vaccinations and they
believe in the decreasing risk
then it's time to take away these
mandates you know like give
people back their lives an opinion
clearly dividing parents
if that's what the school thinks that
they're doing the best not only to
protect our kids but the
staff that work there that we're on
board to follow those rules
elizabeth jesser says her children are
fully vaccinated
they shouldn't have to be forced to wear
a mask the school has the right to set
their policy
i feel that if my children are fully
vaccinated that they should be able to
opt out of wearing the mask
according to mary nieces president of
the clark county education association
there isn't much they can do about the
math school ccsd has put in place
you know ccsd is our employer and we
have all the the confidence that they're
doing what's best for staff and students
as it keeps
you know changing teacher jacob jacoby
understands both sides
and knows keeping the students safe is
top priority
i understand it might be a little bit
stressful for a child to be wearing a
mask all day i give mask breaks i take
my kids outside let them walk around
without masks on
obviously socially distanced ccsd has
made it clear for the time being they
are requiring everyone to wear a mask on
their campuses
until further notice victoria saha 8
news now
now victoria did reach out to the school
district for clarification on mass for
the summer session
and also for the next school year
however she's still awaiting a response